let's go to lj from vegas lj welcome to
the program
hey david how's it going it's going well
good i kind of had a question for you
but i kind of had to set the stage if
that's okay all right
so kind of the comment i wanted to have
is this
kind of
idea that the left is responsible for
all cancel culture
that is
um out there right now at the moment i
have a friend of mine he's not a mega
you know maggot in other words
um but he does lean more towards the
right when it comes to his ideals of
what the left actually represents you
know
um
and we have a lot of just different
discussions about how certain actors
that he likes certain people that he
likes to follow and enjoys listening to
always seem to get yelled at by the left
and they always seem to be
uh trying to be canceled
so
i i my personal introspect and the
things that i give to him in response to
that is
hey
it's more accountability than it is
canceling do you feel that these
actions that this person let's
take you know
um someone who might sexually abuse
somebody or someone who might do
something that's incorrect in the
limelight right and gets caught for it
yeah um
do they do you feel that they're um
personally okay to come back and be
accepted and he says absolutely as long
as they apologize for it and i kind of
want to get your idea of like
what do you think
is a
good way to apologize for someone that
has been let's say cancelled
quote unquote
well okay so first of all
if you kill someone and then say i'm
sorry i did it you don't get out of the
consequences right so let's like first
sometimes it's good to have like an
extreme example to frame the
conversation so first of all we all have
to agree that certain bad acts have to
be punished regardless of remorse i
think right and different people maybe
would disagree on that once we get to
that
take for example someone like do you
know who the chef mario batali is
no i don't he's he was like a tv chef
and he had a big social media presence
and then he was accused i hope i'm being
correct here he was accused of sexual
harassment
for when he was on a program i think
called the chew
and then he basically disappeared from
the social media space
and it's been years and there was
recently some trial and let me see if i
can even find the outcome so we can be
accurate mario batali trial like he was
basically cancelled okay he was found a
few months ago not guilty of indecent
assault and battery on tuesday so
let's imagine how he was canceled how
can he credibly kind of like come back
well i think there's a few components
here number one
um it's been a long enough period
where it's plausible that he could say
even though i was exonerated legally for
what happened
i feel terrible that i made anybody
uncomfortable
i regret my actions
here's what i've done i now understand
you know and so you put together all
these things like okay exoneration in a
trial and it's been a while and he seems
to understand what he did wrong all
right well it seems realistic and
believable and we can say all right let
him start doing his cooking show again
or whatever the case may be and we'll
watch it
contrast that with
someone who's accused of something
horrible
the next day goes i'm sorry if people
were offended and now we're supposed to
say oh yeah that's totally cool yeah
they're fine now in my book no it's it's
not credible it's not plausible so i
don't know that there's necessarily any
sort of like checklist or playbook but
as people we can look at situations and
kind of figure out
um
how we feel about particular situations
and just like be reasonable people
evaluating the world around us
i can give you a specific one because i
just pulled it up right now we were
discussing andrew tate yeah um
and um so i don't know if you know who
he is right i know andrew tate is like
some kind of uh
i don't know he's kind of like a like a
i don't even know how to describe it
he's a guy who i guess had many
relationships with women i don't know
i didn't want to learn about him right
yeah i was forcefully dragged into this
conversation because um he had been
listening to andrew tate recently and
he's like oh no man all he cares about
is like the the the strength of men and
a men's place in the world and he was
discussing all these things and i'm just
like holding my head like please stop
like just
i just don't i can tell you i don't know
enough about that situation to really be
able to comment intelligently
absolutely um and i don't want to give
like a shortened version of it right but
it was more of the fact that it's like
oh andrew tate deleted all the videos
where he's like being a comedian and
he's just trying to make jokes
and i tried to explain to him that
wouldn't be enough right that that is
not a admission of guilt that's not an
omission of right you had the wrong
opinion i agree it's just deleting old
stuff so you can stay on youtube or
whatever it is yep totally yeah that's
not credible it's not doesn't seem
substantive to me i agree yeah so that's
a so i think the answer is we all kind
of intuitively know when these apologies
are credible and then we evaluate that
yeah definitely all right lj thank you
for the call i appreciate everybody who
called in we will take calls again but
no more for today we will take a quick
break and i'll see everybody very soon
one of our sponsors is helix sleep i
have been sleeping on a helix mattress
for years and i always recommend it to
friends you'd simply take this helix
sleep quiz it asks you about your body
type your sleep position whether you
have back pain and then helix will match
you up with the mattress that is
personalized to your needs and they ship
it to you for free another reason i went
with helix is that unlike a lot of
mattress companies out there every
single helix mattress is made in the usa
by a skilled production team which means
when you buy a helix mattress you're
supporting great jobs i'm not the only
one who loves helix helix was recently
awarded number one mattress by both gq
and wired magazine every helix mattress
comes with a 10 or 15 year warranty you
can try it a hundred nights and send it
back for a full refund if you need to
support the david pakman show by getting
your next mattress from helix sleep and
you'll get up to 350 off any mattress
plus two free pillows when you go to
helix sleep.com pacman the link is down
below